Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kamikunters and this is episode five of my personal journey
And I want to share with you some emotional spiritual pieces that I go through on a regular basis
And this is called walking in his will
Share with you one thing that God has reminded me of over and over again in my life and he did so again this
Yesterday, as a matter of fact, I was just prayed through his will for my cancer in my life and how he can be glorified
Through this cancer
And I've shared that with my patients multiple times at how God wants to be glorified
in our body and we should bring him glory in everything we do and that is our ultimate purpose on life
It's to bring him glory and to give him glory and to glorify him with the choices that we make and the things that we do
So what does that mean?
That's that or the rubber meets road sometimes. What does that mean when we have a serious diagnosis?
What does that mean?
As I was asking God that question again yesterday as a matter of fact
He reminded me of when we used to live in Mexico and I don't know if everybody knows our story
But we went did some missionary work in Mexico for a short time. We were just out there for about a year
We are in
Monterey a little town south about the Ray Los Cristales
It a little Bible school called Berea Bible School. I have some pictures of Berea Bible School right here
This is the little church
Empathy inner that was opened doored here
That we used to have Sunday services at
and
This is actually this
Building to the right-hand corner of your slide there is what we built that whole second story when we were down there
We built and I'll never forget I came down there you know to be you know full-time missionaries my wife and we had four kids at the time and
We moved in there that was just a single story building there and
And our one of our jobs down there was going to be to help build this dormitory this extra dormitory
There's three large spaces up there for families because this is a Bible school where young people in Mexico are coming here to
Learned how to be pastors so that they're said out to to start and play at local churches all throughout Mexico
This is this
Braia's been going on since 1970. So it's got a good track history of
Really equipping people to go out and serve the Lord in their hometown those small churches that they will plant and
So there was more and more couples coming and they didn't really have a couples dormitory
So if you came as a buried couple they'd had you know problems with where you live so
They asked if we could help with that so that's one of the things we raised money for when we went down there is to build this extra
dormitory on top of this other building
Well, I could tell you stories about that. It was quite hilarious. I'll just tell you one when I came down there
I brought some tools with me and I brought a hammer and a saw with me and I do
You know, we I would need some things you know down there
I thought well, you're gonna bring some tools down that I have and
Because I had a hammer and a saw the first thing that all the students called me was they said it was a carpenter
So all you know a carpenter because you have a hammer and a saw of course they spoke in Spanish
Which I didn't have fitness to deal with they were talking about I had to have the interpreter for the first period of time when we were down there
We thought it was hilarious because they build everything with concrete down there and because I had a hammer and a saw
I was a carpenter and so my assignment was to make these little teeny
Palettes that were about 15 inches long by night inches wide and a like a little palette rudder on the bottom of these boards
They're all out of rough sun kind of barnwood type things some wood that they had picked up somewhere
So I was cutting and building these little palettes because we actually made all the cement
Cinder blocks. We made them so it was cheaper to make the cinder blocks than to buy the cinder blocks because to buy them it was
I don't know
42 cents a piece and to make them we could make them for a dime a piece
So one of the first things that we did when I when we got there is we we drove into
Monterey which Monterey is about a city of four million people at that time. We drove in there on a rickety old pickup truck
That this is I think my first day there
So we just got there and and my wife and kids are like okay, we're this Ford cut rudder. We know where we are and
David the head of the Bible school said hey, you're gonna come with me
He spoke some English he'll come with me. We got to go pick up the cement block
Vibrator so it was a vibration plate and then this mold that you would pour the concrete into and you
It would vibrate for one minute to settle all the concrete out and then you you actually put the mold on the
Palette that I was going to make and then you pour the concrete in there and vibrate fiber
Cosset down and then you take
Carefully take the mold out and carefully lift the palette and most the young Bible schools did all students did all that work
And then they go set it on a flat concrete service and let it dry in the sun and then the next day flip it
Dry in the sun again. It was ready to use so that's what we did and I'd ever forget going to pick up that
Vibration play to that mold in
In Boltrae. We got stopped by the police
What I'd experienced that was I was in the middle
passage or seat of this
Probably 1970s little
Middisher pickup or go to pick this thing up with the police stop us of course they're speaking everything in Spanish
I have the faintest idea what they're talking about and then we had to follow the police
They just spoke for 15 minutes outside of the truck David was speaking to the police officer
We had to follow the police and the whole thing was is that the truck was donated to the Bible school and
It had no license plate on it
So that's why they picked us up. We had to follow them over to where this little taco stand was and we had to buy them tacos
In order for let's go so that puts my first experience
With the police yeah of Mexico, which I thought hey, this is great if we could just buy you know the police officer
A big back and have it dot give us a speedy ticket
Then it would never go on our
Record and we're sure it's wouldn't go up. Why don't we do this in the States? I thought this is this is like a fantastic
So funny little stories. I was ill you know, that was for down there, but he doesn't say we worked down there for a year
And we were I taught at the Bible school by wife and kids worked with the orphanage that was connected to that
But we realized quite so that the orphanage had a lot of help
We thought we were gonna do more work with the orphanage and we really felt God said to stand there to work with the poorest of the
poor so we started our own ministry with the shanty tones
There was a shanty tone in Monterey that we went to multiple times the wonderful place the wonderful thing about Mexico is every place
I got to go I got to preach so that was great
So of course I had an interpreter for most of the time and tell we got there. We were there longer and we I could speak a little bit better Spanish
And then we worked with the shanty towns at the border
The border towns are even more impoverished at least at that time
They were this was back of the 90s that we live back there and it was so that's where we are we concentrated our work
The shanty towns were people where people live basically in cardboard tin boxes
And it was just really really impoverished people the lowest end of the the socio-economic scale
And we ministered we didn't just give out stuff
We shared the gospel we preached and one of the quotes that I said at the end what we left was I just lit
We just literally felt like we were putting drops in a bucket that had no bottom
That's what we felt like we felt like did we do anything to break God glory through this
And that was our biggest struggle
We ended up leaving there after I was done teaching by year there that we had committed to and we came back partially
Mainly because two of our kids were developing such horrible allergies that they were they were sick quite often and
And that whole area is in just a bowl and the all the macheel adora plants in the border towns in
Mademora and such just spewied out toxins and our kids were getting really sick
And that could be a major reason why I got cancer
Because as I tested myself it came up mercury toxicity, but other toxins and that's when my cancer all began is when I came back from there
So
We ended up really feel called to leave there
But one of the things that we were so conflicted with was did we really help anybody?
Did we really did we did the CDs this giant fruit of
You know hundreds of people coming to the Lord well, we actually did every time we went preach at the Shanty town
Everybody came forward to accept Christ
But it was the same people as long as they got a handout so it was it was very
strong
rice bowl
Christianity and it was that was very frustrating me to me because if you know me at all it's it's I don't I'm not in
Puddle shallow Christianity, so we give our whole life to him
Everything we have that's what means being a Christian not just because you went to church got baptized instead of prayer
And and went to confirmation and you do your little diddly thing
That's not what it means to be a follower of Christ
It's why I don't even like use the word Christianity. Are you a follower of Jesus Christ?
Are you listening him? Are you obeyed him as best you can? Are you asking him for grace to be obedient as best you can?
That's what it means to be a believer and
When you serve him many times
Praise God he doesn't show us the fruits of our labor because we'd probably
Get proud and that's not good for us
So God didn't reveal the fruits of our labor very often it was so it was discouraging what do you feel like you leave some place?
I'll never forget
Get to the point of my story here driving home in our you hall
Couldn't find a picture of us with our you hall of course back in the 90s
That was before digital cameras and we didn't have so a cell phone even at the time
That's not our suburban. That's not the you hall
But that's the exact same you size you hall that we had and we were driving home
My wife in our two-yugest had already flowed home two weeks before
Myself and my two oldest kids who were
13 and 15 I think at the time were driving home at our
10 12-year-old suburban when we were driving home a 10-year-old suburban and a you hall trailer just like this one
We had all of our possessions in that in that suburban edit that you hall and
I was driving home when I remember I had
When I when we went to Mexico, I had given up my license that like the King Lord
We're all in both feet with this with you whatever path you have us on
Whether you ever bring us back or not we're all in so driving home 35 years old at the time no license to practice
No other real skill sets to fall back on
We had nobody we had went self-supported so we had to spend every last penny of our money
We had zero buddy coming back. I had barely enough money for gas driving home and my two girls who's probably and maybe it was an Iowa
Drive-in through Iowa that they had fallen asleep and I was just I just broke down on a road driving
Physically emotionally broke down just cried out to the Lord Lord. Why?
Why why did you have us do this? I don't I don't know what we're gonna do in our life
We're going back to the real world now where you actually need money to get around and I have nothing no license
What did you have us do this for and it was one of those a few times in my life that I could honestly say that I really
Heard God in my head wasn't this cloud-opening audible voice, but the Lord said to me quite clearly
He said if I had asked you to do all of this for just one person
would you
And that's what I heard in my head
But the wisdom that he gave me with that was even deeper so I do what he meant, which was
Shut up. I gave everything my son to save you
You are not your own anymore and if I want to use you to send you to Mexico to die
To help save one person and not even tell you about it. That's my business not yours and
That hit me hard that shaped my life from that point on and that shapes my life
From what I deal with any struggles what I deal with its kids are diagnosis and that
You know most likely this is going to take my life
I'm a realist
It's Lord. What what's the purpose in this?
That's my question for him Lord. What's the purpose of this because I want to bring you glory
So tell me how I could use the situation that you've allowed in my life to glorify you and
And that's the whole point. That's what I want you to look at with your situation
You're in. How could you use this Lord to bring you glory?
and
I think that's the question of a Christian when they go through difficult times
That should be the question. I know we go through all sorts of other thoughts at our mind
And we feel sorry for ourselves and we why did we cry and God allows that he just listens to it
And he's there to comfort us, but ultimately we have to get to the point Lord
How could you use this to glorify yourself and he keeps bringing back the verse to me that we are not our own
For you were bought with a price and if I gave myself to Christ and I am his I am his
I'm not my own anymore. I don't have a right to argue with whatever he puts in front of me
The struggles the problems the cancer the disease the deaths the happiness the joy
It's not mind anymore. It's his so we need to glorify God in our body in our heart in our motions our actions our thoughts our deeds
Everything and that's a process. That's called sanctification
We don't just reach this point of Nirvana where we're this Holy spiritual people. That's just a lie. It never happens
It's a daily process
And we're gonna go through struggles. We're gonna go through emotions and it'll come out
And we need godly people to come alongside us and say it's okay
God's got this crawl back into his arms let him snuggle you let him let his figures rub through your hair
Let him patch you on your on your cheek and say listen honey. I got this and
That's what we need
John Piper was is a pastor that we went to his church for years. He's retired or we listened to him constantly on
YouTube and his books
I'd highly highly recommend his work. He's probably one of the most gifted orators of our time
He's quoted a quote of his ministry as God is most glorified in us when we are most satisfied in him
When we are
Seed the joy of our salvation. That's what God has glorified in us because now it's not about the cancer
It's not about the financial collapse. It's not about the problems that we're having
It's God that we are so satisfied in our heavenly Father
That that's when he is glorified in us
That's my challenge to you so render to him
Get on your knees if you need just repent of your selfishness and your selfish thoughts and your struggles
He's there for you. He understands your humanness
It's not a bad thing to go through those things
But ultimately we can't stay there. We need to find joy in him
That's my challenge for you in this episode and again these episodes are just what I'm going through
So I'm just going to be dead pan honest with you the whole way. Thanks so much. Love you all